what's the weirdest thing you've tracked
about yourself weirdest thing I've
tracked good question I know that it
entered a-- during that quest for
fatness and I actually outdid myself
with that recently I consumed 15,000
calories in 20 minutes
Wow and then had close to 30 meals the
next day and clocked in his lower body
thought the next day but that's for the
that's for the 4-hour chef which is the
next one but the the weirdest thing I
tracked to try to identify calories in
versus calories out I had to look at
excretions actually measured my poo for
a while
engrams ended before and after the
question that I'm certain is on the mind
of our audience how do you do that so
for those of you who want to try this at
home it's not very fancy first of all
caveat you do that poo on the scale
don't do that right you need you need a
container of some type and then it's
pretty self-explanatory
I recommend grams I'll leave it at that
all right good moving on yes um and and
you know I do this that you don't have